This is 99% indisible. I'm Roman Mars. We've wanted to do a story about gerrymandering for years. Once you take it as a given that we want to live in a representative democracy, the next question becomes, how are we best represented? We need to divide ourselves into groups, but on what basis should the lines be drawn? Basic geography is a place to start, but there what basis should the lines be drawn? Basic geography is a place to start, but there are always exceptions and nuances that make defining voting districts solely along geographic boundaries problematic. I think of this as a design problem,
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible），我是罗曼·马尔斯。多年来，我们一直想做一期关于杰利蝾螈（选区划分不公）的节目。一旦你接受了我们想要生活在代议制民主国家这一前提，接下来的问题就是：我们如何才能得到最好的代表？我们需要将自己分成不同的群体，但应该基于什么原则来划分界限呢？基本的地理位置是一个出发点，但总会有例外和细微差别，使得仅根据地理边界来定义选区变得困难。我认为这是一个设计问题，
maybe the most important design problem of democracy. Our friends over at 538 recently dove deep into this topic with a six-part series that examines Jerry Mandering in different states around the country. It's called the Jerry Mandering Project. It turns out each state that they profiled is dealing with representation and Jerry Mandering differently. The states are really acting as the laboratories of democracy that US Supreme Court Justice Brandeis said they were. We are going to spend the whole episode this week exploring that series and playing scenes
也许是民主制度中最重要的设计问题。我们的朋友538网站（538）最近深入探讨了这个话题，制作了一个六集系列节目，审视了全国不同州的杰利蝾螈现象。它被称为“杰利蝾螈项目”。事实证明，他们所调查的每个州在处理代表权和杰利蝾螈问题上的方式各不相同。正如美国最高法院大法官布兰代斯所言，各州确实在充当民主的实验室。本周，我们将用整集节目来探索该系列，并播放
from four different episodes about Jerry Mandering in four different states. Our guide along the way will be the host of the Jerry Mandering Project and producer at 538, Galen Drook. Thank you for being here, Galen. Hey Roman, thanks for having me. So this might seem like an obvious question, but just laid out for us. What is Jerry Mandarin? Jerry Mandarin, at its most basic, is drawing district lines to achieve a specific goal.
来自四个不同州关于杰利蝾螈的四集节目的片段。我们的向导将是“杰利蝾螈项目”的主持人兼538网站制作人盖伦·德鲁克。谢谢你来到这里，盖伦。嘿，罗曼，谢谢你的邀请。这听起来可能是一个显而易见的问题，但请为我们解释一下：什么是杰利蝾螈？杰利蝾螈，最基本的意思就是为了实现特定目标而绘制选区界限。
I think the most common form of Jerry Mandarin that people are familiar with is partisan Jerry Mandarin, which would be drawing lines in a way that advantage one party over another, but you could also draw lines to protect incumbents, or you could racially gerrymandor to dilute minorities voting power. So there's more than one kind of gerrymandering, but at its core, it's just manipulating lines with a goal in mind. So implicit in the idea that a gerrymandor district is manipulated is that there's some natural way that a district should be drawn and that doesn't seem like that's I mean How do you really determine what the natural state of a district is?
我认为人们最熟悉的杰利蝾螈形式是党派杰利蝾螈，即以有利于某一政党的方式划分界限；但你也可以为了保护现任议员而划分界限，或者通过种族杰利蝾螈来稀释少数族裔的投票权。所以杰利蝾螈不止一种，但其核心就是为了实现某个目标而操纵界限。那么，杰利蝾螈选区被操纵这一概念中隐含着一种假设，即选区应该有一种“自然”的划分方式，但这似乎……我的意思是，你如何真正确定一个选区的自然状态是什么？
Yes, you're right. There is no redistricting plan that is Blessed by the grace of God. You know, there are not rivers, streams, mountains, and redistricting plans. Oftentimes people will just refer to something as gerrymandered when they don't like the result, or if it looks funny. And who decides how districts get drawn, generally? For the most part, state legislators come up with maps that are then approved by state governors. And in some cases, states have overhauled the process to give the power to an independent commission, but for the most part, it's state governments. And the way that the party in control can achieve an advantage over the party out of control is by packing and cracking their voters, which would mean in some instances putting a lot of that
是的，你说得对。没有任何重划选区计划是受到上帝恩典祝福的。你知道，重划选区计划里并没有河流、溪流或山脉。通常人们在不喜欢结果或选区形状看起来很滑稽时，就会称其为杰利蝾螈。那么，通常是谁决定选区如何划分呢？在大多数情况下，州议员会提出地图，然后由州长批准。在某些情况下，各州彻底改革了这一程序，将权力交给了一个独立委员会，但大部分情况下还是由州政府负责。掌握控制权的政党可以通过“打包”和“裂解”选民来获得相对于在野党的优势，这意味着在某些情况下，将大量
party's voters in one district. So is to make them waste a bunch of their votes because theoretically any vote over 51% would be a wasted vote. It's not helping to elect anybody. And then on the other hand, you have cracking, which would be dividing up that party's voters so that they can't reach 51% in any one district, forcing them to waste votes in another way. So in the 538 series, Gailin looked at four different states that are either currently dealing with or have recently dealt with the question of Jerry Mandry. And we're going to hear tape and talk a little bit about each of those states. We'll start with Wisconsin. So just a little background.
该党选民集中在一个选区，从而使他们浪费掉大量选票，因为理论上超过51%的任何选票都是浪费的选票，对选举任何人都没有帮助。另一方面，还有“裂解”，即将该党选民分散开来，使他们在任何一个选区都无法达到51%，从而以另一种方式迫使他们浪费选票。在538的系列节目中，盖伦考察了四个目前正在处理或最近处理过杰利蝾螈问题的州。我们将听取录音并讨论其中每一个州。我们先从威斯康星州开始。先简单介绍一下背景。
In 2010, Wisconsin Republicans won unified control of the state government. This was a particularly big deal because it happened to be a redistricting year. It was the first time in decades that a single party had had total control of the state government as the state redrew its political maps. And the Republicans took full advantage. They drew maps that Democrats allege are very favorable to Republican candidates. This obviously didn't sit well with the Democrats and they filed suit. Now for a long time, anti-Jerrymandering activists have been trying to find cases that they could
2010年，威斯康星州共和党人赢得了州政府的统一控制权。这是一件大事，因为那恰好是重划选区的一年。这是几十年来单一政党在州政府重划政治地图时首次拥有完全控制权。共和党人充分利用了这一点。他们绘制的地图被民主党人指控非常偏袒共和党候选人。这显然让民主党人感到不满，于是他们提起了诉讼。长期以来，反杰利蝾螈活动人士一直试图寻找案例，
bring before the Supreme Court to try to get a ruling that this kind of political manipulation is unconstitutional, that it violates either the First Amendment or the Fourteenth Amendment. And one civil rights lawyer, in particular a man named Peter Earl, started digging into the Wisconsin case in uncovering details. He found out that Republicans had drawn these maps in a secret office, and that Republican lawmakers had signed secrecy agreements not to discuss the shape of the new districts. But Earl didn't know the extent to which Republicans had gone to secure a partisan advantage. We'll let Galen take it from here.
将其诉诸最高法院，试图获得一项裁决，认定这种政治操纵是违宪的，违反了第一修正案或第十四修正案。一位名叫彼得·厄尔的民权律师开始深入挖掘威斯康星州的案件并揭露细节。他发现共和党人在一个秘密办公室里绘制了这些地图，并且共和党议员签署了保密协议，不得讨论新选区的形状。但厄尔并不知道共和党人为确保党派优势走到了什么地步。我们让盖伦从这里开始讲。
Earl and his partner still didn't have a full picture of how the maps were drawn, a detail that would be key to their case. So they continued to dig deeper, and they noticed the email records from some people. Didn they noticed the email records from some people didn't match the email records from the people they were communicating with. And that raised suspicions and we began to demand more and more information. And the court finally ordered them to turn over
厄尔和他的合伙人仍然没有掌握地图是如何绘制的全貌，而这一细节对他们的案件至关重要。因此，他们继续深入挖掘，注意到一些人的电子邮件记录。他们注意到一些人的电子邮件记录与他们所交流的人的记录不匹配。这引起了怀疑，我们开始要求提供越来越多的信息。法院最终命令他们交出
the hard drive so we can forensically look at them. So the attorney is hired a forensic examiner. He was able to determine that hundreds of thousands of documents had been deleted with a wiping software prior to the hard drives being turned over to us. But they were able to uncover the deleted documents, including a number of spreadsheets. And those spreadsheets are what really told the story. We were able to see every iteration of the map as they went from the baseline to the map that
硬盘，以便我们进行取证检查。律师们聘请了一位法医鉴定专家。他能够确定在硬盘移交给我们之前，有数十万份文件被擦除软件删除了。但他们成功恢复了被删除的文件，包括一些电子表格。正是这些电子表格真正讲述了故事。我们能够看到地图从基准线到最终采用的地图的每一次迭代。
they finally adopted. The map drawers used years of partisan voting data to the map that they finally adopted. The MAP-DRIRs used years of partisan voting data to design maps that strongly favored Republicans. We found out that there was a professor by the name of Keith Gaddy from the University of Oklahoma, who had been hired by the Republicans to develop a very sophisticated, multi-variant regression analysis of partisan performance based on votes in the assembly districts from 2006,
地图绘制者使用了多年的党派投票数据来设计强烈偏袒共和党人的地图。我们发现，俄克拉荷马大学的一位名叫基思·加迪的教授被共和党人聘请，利用2006年、
2008, 2010. And they actually downloaded this proxy into the software that they were using to draw the maps. So when the MAMTAR has moved the lines on the software, they could see how it affected the partisan lean of the districts in real time. The three Republicans who were responsible for drawing these maps declined to be interviewed on the record. And then they kept up in the ante in terms of how many Republicans seats they were guaranteed. The map they ultimately came up with was designed to elect Republicans to 59 of the 99 assembly seats with just 49% of the vote, a strong majority with a minority of the statewide vote.
2008年和2010年众议院选区的投票数据，开发了一种非常复杂的、多变量的党派表现回归分析。他们实际上将这个代理数据下载到了他们绘制地图所使用的软件中。因此，当制图员在软件上移动界限时，他们可以实时看到这如何影响选区的党派倾向。负责绘制这些地图的三名共和党人拒绝接受正式采访。他们不断提高筹码，以确保他们能获得多少共和党席位。他们最终得出的地图旨在以仅49%的选票让共和党人赢得99个众议院席位中的59个，即以全州少数选票获得强有力的多数席位。
They had accounted for, in effect, the largest swings between Democratic turnout and Republican turnout during the preceding decade. The plaintiffs are now presenting those spreadsheets to the Supreme Court as evidence that the Republicans set out to disadvantage Democrats. The moment that we realized this was like a, it was like a eureka moment and the rage, the anger that I felt, the outrage that these people would commit this level of a crime
他们实际上考虑了过去十年中民主党投票率和共和党投票率之间最大的波动。原告现在正将这些电子表格作为证据提交给最高法院，证明共和党人蓄意让民主党人处于不利地位。当我们意识到这一点时，那就像是一个“尤里卡时刻”，我感到的愤怒、那种暴怒，即这些人竟然会对民主进程犯下这种程度的罪行，
against the democratic process was just astounding. At that point, we decided we were going to do something about this. I mean, this sounds just completely pernicious and horrible. So what is the defense against this? Like, what is the actual argument that can be made? Is this a smoking gun? So the most blunt argument that Wisconsin Republicans will make is that partisan gerrymandering isn't illegal. State legislators have been drawing maps that advantage one party over another for like over a hundred years.
简直令人震惊。在那一刻，我们决定必须为此做点什么。我的意思是，这听起来完全是恶毒且可怕的。那么，对此有什么防御措施吗？比如，有什么实际的论点可以提出来？这是确凿的证据吗？威斯康星州共和党人最直白的论点是：党派杰利蝾螈并不违法。一百多年来，州议员们一直在绘制有利于某一政党的地图。
And so they're basically saying this is a bit hypocritical, you know, why are Democrats all of a sudden outraged about partisan gerrymandering after they've been doing it for years themselves? Democrats in the case will respond and say, you know, this is a civil rights issue and it's gotten so far out of hand that the Supreme Court does finally need to step in. And then the Republicans will say, okay, if the Supreme Court is going to step in, then you have to have a very clear standard of what is and is not fair in drawing maps. And ultimately, that's a really, really difficult line to draw.
所以他们基本上是在说这有点虚伪，你知道，为什么民主党人在自己多年来一直这样做之后，突然对党派杰利蝾螈感到愤怒了呢？该案中的民主党人会回应说，这是一个民权问题，而且已经失控到最高法院确实需要介入的地步。然后共和党人会说，好吧，如果最高法院要介入，那么你必须有一个非常明确的标准，来界定在绘制地图时什么是公平的，什么是不公平的。归根结底，那是一条非常、非常难以划定的界限。
Right. Because the judicial branch doesn't really want to get involved with drawing every line on a map. I mean, you could see why they'd be reticent to do this, that this is up to the legislature. For sure. I mean, so for conservatives on the court who strongly believe that judicial overreach is a threat to our governmental system, yes, that would be terrible. If courts around the country were basically drawing maps that were supposed to be drawn by the state legislature. So if they are going to wait into this issue, they want to be able to have like a very clear standard for what is and is not fair and then get themselves back out of the process so that state legislatures can follow those guidelines. Anthony Kennedy has made it clear in the past that he does not like partisan gerrymandering.
没错。因为司法部门并不真的想参与绘制地图上的每一条线。我的意思是，你可以看出他们为什么对此持保留态度，因为这应该由立法机构决定。当然。我的意思是，对于法院中坚信司法越权是对我们政府系统威胁的保守派来说，是的，那将是可怕的。如果全国各地的法院都在绘制本应由州议会绘制的地图。所以，如果他们要介入这个问题，他们希望能够有一个非常明确的标准来界定什么是公平的，什么是不公平的，然后让自己退出这个过程，以便州议会能够遵循这些指导方针。安东尼·肯尼迪过去曾明确表示，他不喜欢党派杰利蝾螈。
He's reticent, however, of waiting into this for that exact reason. He doesn't want courts across the country repeatedly getting involved in this issue and drawing maps that the legislature should be drawing. And so where does the Wisconsin situation currently stand? We are waiting for a decision. The Supreme Court heard oral arguments last fall, and we will have a decision in this case by June. And, you know, the decision in this case could be a pretty big deal.
然而，他因为同样的原因对介入此事持保留态度。他不希望全国各地的法院反复卷入这个问题，去绘制本应由立法机构绘制的地图。那么威斯康星州的情况目前处于什么阶段？我们正在等待裁决。最高法院去年秋天听取了口头辩论，我们将在六月前得到该案的裁决。而且，你知道，该案的裁决可能会产生非常重大的影响。
If the Supreme Court sides with the Wisconsin Democrats, that could mean that there's a whole lot more court cases following the same model, saying that the maps in those states are illegal and need to be redrawn. So Wisconsin is a pretty obvious example of partisan gerrymandering, but now we're going to turn to North Carolina where legislators have drawn lines with race in mind. The Voting Rights Act has been interpreted over the years to mean that states need to draw
如果最高法院站在威斯康星州民主党人一边，那可能意味着会有更多遵循同样模式的法院案件，声称这些州的地图是非法的，需要重新绘制。所以威斯康星州是一个非常明显的党派杰利蝾螈例子，但现在我们要转向北卡罗来纳州，那里的立法者在绘制界限时考虑了种族因素。《投票权法案》多年来被解释为意味着各州需要绘制
maps that don't dilute minority voters and allow minority communities to elect candidates of their choice. In North Carolina, that meant in the early 1990s, maps were drawn so that certain districts would favor African-American candidates. It worked. North Carolina elected black representatives to the U.S. House for the first time since reconstruction. This was a huge success for the first time since reconstruction.
不稀释少数族裔选民投票权，并允许少数族裔社区选出他们选择的候选人的地图。在北卡罗来纳州，这意味着在20世纪90年代初，地图的绘制是为了让某些选区有利于非裔美国人候选人。这奏效了。北卡罗来纳州自重建时期以来首次选出了黑人代表进入美国众议院。这对非裔美国人社区来说是一个巨大的成功。
This was a huge success for the African American community, but it was also good for another group. North Carolina Republicans, to understand why consider this. Black North Carolinians overwhelmingly vote Democratic. By packing these voters into a small number of districts where black candidates will likely win, the legislature also diminished black voting power in other districts around the state, allowing Republicans to dominate the overall political landscape of the state. Different people in North Carolina have very
这对非裔美国人社区来说是一个巨大的成功，但对另一个群体也有好处。北卡罗来纳州的共和党人。要理解为什么，请考虑这一点：北卡罗来纳州的黑人绝大多数投票支持民主党。通过将这些选民打包到少数几个黑人候选人很可能获胜的选区中，立法机构也削弱了该州其他选区的黑人投票权，从而使共和党人能够主导该州的整体政治格局。北卡罗来纳州的不同人有非常
different opinions about this, and we're going to play some tape now from the North Carolina episode of the Jerry Manning Project that illustrates the super complicated dynamic. I have never personally been one that think that increasing the numbers of the black caucus and Congress, for example, necessarily equated to a plus for the African American community. Derek Smith, a political action chair for the state and WACP. They can ensure that African Americans get sent to legislative bodies and that looks good on election day when they can stand up and say, look, look at what we did for you all. We helped get Eva Clayton and Mel Watt into Congress in the 1990s. But on the whole, the effect was that that was when the state began to shift towards a
不同的看法，我们现在要播放一些来自“杰利蝾螈项目”北卡罗来纳州那一集的录音，它展示了这种超级复杂的动态。我个人从来不认为增加国会中黑人核心小组的人数必然等同于对非裔美国人社区的加分。德里克·史密斯，州全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）的政治行动主席。他们可以确保非裔美国人被送入立法机构，这在选举日看起来不错，当他们站出来说，看，看看我们为你们所有人做了什么。我们在90年代帮助伊娃·克莱顿和梅尔·瓦特进入了国会。但总的来说，其效果是，那是该州开始转向
Republican-dominated caucus and that happened all throughout the South. He's in favor of African-American voters, influencing various districts. I've always thought that African-American voices that are numerous and loud enough and active in many different places, lend to the likelihood that policy decisions will consider African-Americans more than they do. And white and black Democrats can form coalitions to elect minority candidates more easily than they were once able to in North Carolina. Smith points to a famous example. President Obama is a classic example of that. If we confuse together on common interests which affect the governance for the good of all, then
共和党主导的核心小组的时候，这种情况在整个南方都发生了。他赞成非裔美国选民影响各个选区。我一直认为，如果非裔美国人的声音足够多、足够响亮，并且在许多不同的地方活跃，那么政策决策就更有可能比以往更多地考虑非裔美国人。白人和黑人民主党人可以比过去在北卡罗来纳州更容易地结成联盟来选出少数族裔候选人。史密斯指出了一个著名的例子。奥巴马总统就是一个典型的例子。如果我们为了共同利益而团结在一起，这些利益影响着所有人的福祉，那么
it doesn't matter your race. Reggie Weaver of Common Cause tends to agree. An argument has been made that yes, in justification of racially packed districts that minority candidates would not be elected any other way. There may be some truth to that, I don't know. To me then, the answer isn't to pack districts and weaken the minority voice in other areas. He says that that won't get at the root of the problem. What I personally am more interested in is, you know,
你的种族就不重要了。共同事业组织（Common Cause）的雷吉·韦弗对此表示赞同。有人提出过这样的论点，即为了证明种族打包选区的合理性，少数族裔候选人可能无法通过其他方式当选。这可能有一些道理，我不知道。对我来说，答案不是打包选区并削弱其他地区的少数族裔声音。他说这无法触及问题的根源。我个人更感兴趣的是，你知道，
why is it, you know, why is it that I as an African-American, I'm gonna have a weaker chance in a purely competitive district just along parts of life, you know, why isn't it? And I think that that gets to deeper questions that we are yet to resolve as a country about race. But the idea that less emphasis should be put on race when drawing districts is not a universal one. Again, here's Pam Stubbs,
为什么，你知道，为什么作为一名非裔美国人，我在一个纯粹竞争性的选区中获胜的机会会更小？你知道，为什么会这样？我认为这触及了我们作为一个国家在种族问题上尚未解决的更深层次的问题。但绘制选区时应减少对种族强调的观点并非普遍存在。再次重申，这是帕姆·斯塔布斯，
who worked in Greensboro's 12th District Office when it was first won by Melwatt in 1993. Until the playing ground is level in America then we will always need our minority districts and so far the playing ground is not level. Stubbs is unsure that African-American lawmakers will maintain their ranks if these districts are dismantled and academic research suggests that that could cause some ripple effects. The presence of minority lawmakers can boost voter turnout among minorities. It can also increase their trust and engagement with politicians.
她在1993年梅尔·瓦特首次赢得格林斯博罗第12选区时曾在该办公室工作。在美国的竞争环境变得公平之前，我们将永远需要我们的少数族裔选区，而到目前为止，竞争环境并不公平。斯塔布斯不确定如果这些选区被拆除，非裔美国议员是否能保持他们的席位，学术研究表明这可能会产生一些连锁反应。少数族裔议员的存在可以提高少数族裔的选民投票率。它还可以增加他们对政治人物的信任和参与度。
One study, done after Democrats began drawing down the black populations in minority districts in the 2000s, showed that minority members of Congress are more likely to advocate for their community's priorities than white members of the same party. You have to realize most of those minority districts were created after the 1990 census, when there was hardly any minority representation across the country in Congress. So even though they're safe now, you have to understand why they were created. Case in point. Visit the Civil Rights Museum in Greensboro. My name is Cassandra Williams, and I would like to personally welcome you to the International Civil Rights Center and Museum.
一项研究显示，在民主党人开始减少2000年代少数族裔选区中的黑人人口后，少数族裔国会议员比同党的白人议员更有可能为他们社区的优先事项进行辩护。你必须意识到，大多数少数族裔选区是在1990年人口普查后创建的，当时国会中几乎没有任何少数族裔代表。所以即使他们现在很安全，你也必须理解他们为什么被创建。举个例子。参观格林斯博罗的民权博物馆。我叫卡桑德拉·威廉姆斯，我想亲自欢迎你们来到国际民权中心和博物馆。
When you arrive at the Voting Rights Act section of the museum, there's a striking installment. Now, when we look at this list of the wall here, you see African Americans elected to federal or statewide constitutional offices. It's a Florida ceiling list showing the date African-American lawmakers were elected from each state. Let's look at North Carolina. In the years right after the Civil War during Reconstruction, we see that there were four black men elected to represent the state of
当你到达博物馆的《投票权法案》部分时，有一个引人注目的装置。现在，当我们看墙上的这份名单时，你会看到当选为联邦或州级宪法职位的非裔美国人。这是一份从天花板到地板的名单，显示了每个州选出非裔美国议员的日期。让我们看看北卡罗来纳州。在内战结束后的重建时期，我们看到有四名黑人当选代表北卡罗来纳州
North Carolina in the House of Representatives. But then we see about a hundred year gap before Mrs. Eva Clayton was elected to represent North Carolina. In state after state across the South, that that 100 year gap persisted. We see that same gap in South Carolina. We see it in Alabama, Florida. We see 1871 and then another 100 year gap is there. We can see it in Georgia, in Louisiana, from 1875 and then not until 1991. In many states, that gap only ends in the early 1990s, when states were forced to draw majority black districts. So it's easy to understand why the conversation
进入众议院。但随后我们看到在伊娃·克莱顿女士当选代表北卡罗来纳州之前，大约有一百年的空白期。在南方的一个又一个州，那一百年的空白期持续存在。我们在南卡罗来纳州看到了同样的空白。我们在阿拉巴马州、佛罗里达州也看到了。我们看到1871年，然后又是100年的空白。我们在佐治亚州、路易斯安那州也能看到，从1875年开始，直到1991年才结束。在许多州，这种空白直到20世纪90年代初才结束，当时各州被迫划定黑人占多数的选区。所以很容易理解为什么关于
about majority minority districts can be so contentious and emotional. If the law favors unpacking minority districts, it could become more difficult to ensure that African Americans are elected at the same rates that they have been. For example, North Carolina's state legislative map is currently being redrawn to unpack the majority minority districts. The chair of the legislative black caucus, Angela Bryan, is likely to lose her seat in the redraw. I truly regret losing my district and the coalition that had been formed in that district. I regret that. At the same time, the Jaramandering was a burden.
多数少数族裔选区的对话会如此具有争议性和情感色彩。如果法律倾向于拆解少数族裔选区，那么确保非裔美国人以他们过去那样的比例当选可能会变得更加困难。例如，北卡罗来纳州的州立法地图目前正在重新绘制，以拆解多数少数族裔选区。立法黑人核心小组主席安吉拉·布莱恩很可能会在重划中失去她的席位。我真心遗憾失去我的选区以及在该选区形成的联盟。我对此感到遗憾。与此同时，杰利蝾螈是一种负担。
She says it's for the best. I'm convinced that even if people like me lose out to have a firm foundation upon which we are doing this redistricting. We will be better off over time. I mean, this was the episode that most broke my brain, I think. I don't know what it was like for you putting it together, but there are so many interests that have to be balanced and so many interests that I really support and want to have happen. You know, it's crazy how many values you have to juggle to draw these lines. Yeah, and I mean, this is really even just the tip of the iceberg when it comes to all
她说这是为了最好的结果。我确信，即使像我这样的人输了，为了有一个我们进行这次重划的坚实基础，从长远来看，我们会过得更好。我的意思是，我认为这是最让我崩溃的一集。我不知道你制作它时是什么感觉，但有太多的利益需要平衡，有太多的利益是我真正支持并希望实现的。你知道，为了划定这些界限，你必须权衡的价值观之多真是令人疯狂。是的，我的意思是，当涉及到所有
of the interests that you have to consider in drawing a district map. This is a really difficult conversation, especially for Democrats to have, because on one hand, they want to have the best shot at winning majorities that they can. On the other hand, if we are going to no longer have majority minority districts, that might involve amending the Voting Rights Act,
你在绘制选区地图时必须考虑的利益时，这真的只是冰山一角。这是一个非常困难的对话，特别是对民主党人来说，因为一方面，他们希望尽可能多地赢得多数席位。另一方面，如果我们不再拥有多数少数族裔选区，那可能涉及修改《投票权法案》，
and that's a really difficult conversation for Democrats to have because as a platform, Democrats, you know, support enhancing the voting power of minorities. So we've talked about this value of competitiveness and that brings us to the state of Arizona. And in 2011, they tried to give power to draw maps over to an independent commission. And a big part of the goal was to increase competitiveness and elections. Can you describe what the thinking was and why they created commission to preference this particular value?
这对民主党人来说是一个非常困难的对话，因为作为一个政纲，民主党人支持增强少数族裔的投票权。所以我们讨论了竞争力的价值，这把我们带到了亚利桑那州。2011年，他们试图将绘制地图的权力交给一个独立委员会。而目标的一个重要部分是提高选举的竞争力。你能描述一下当时的想法，以及他们为什么要创建一个优先考虑这一特定价值的委员会吗？
Yes. If you ask Americans, they love competitive elections. Of course, from there, it gets a little more complicated. But in general, competition is a thing that Americans value, like what's more American than competition. In 2000, Arizona threw a ballot initiative, meaning that just Arizona's all across the state voted on this, you know, single item saying, do you want to create an independent commission to draw the state maps, take the power away from the state legislature.
是的。如果你问美国人，他们热爱竞争性选举。当然，从那里开始，事情就变得有点复杂了。但总的来说，竞争是美国人所珍视的东西，比如还有什么比竞争更“美国”的呢？2000年，亚利桑那州通过了一项投票倡议，这意味着全州的亚利桑那人就这一单一议题进行了投票，说：你们想创建一个独立委员会来绘制州地图，从州议会手中夺走权力吗？
And Arizona's voted yes. And so for the first time in 2001, an independent commission drew the maps. And then for a second time in 2011, an independent commission also drew the maps. And in doing this, you know, the drafters of this ballot initiative had to basically say, these are the criteria for drawing the maps that this independent commission has to follow. And uniquely in Arizona, one of those criteria was competitiveness. In fact, it's the only state in the country that requires an independent commission or even lawmakers for that matter to try to make districts competitive.
亚利桑那人投了赞成票。因此，2001年，一个独立委员会首次绘制了地图。然后2011年，独立委员会第二次绘制了地图。在这样做时，你知道，这项投票倡议的起草者基本上必须说，这些是独立委员会必须遵循的绘制地图的标准。在亚利桑那州，其中一个标准是竞争力，这很独特。事实上，它是全国唯一一个要求独立委员会（甚至立法者）尝试使选区具有竞争力的州。
By competitive, you mean that depending on the candidate, it's maybe, I don't know, equally likely that a Democrat or a Republican can be elected. I mean, how do you define competitiveness? Yeah. I mean, in the kind of wonky world of 538, we define competitiveness as within five points of the national average in a presidential election. So basically a district where you would expect a close race. Right. And so this got very controversial, very fast. Can you tell us what happened? So at the time in 2011, Republicans controlled both chambers of the state legislature, and they were
通过“有竞争力”，你的意思是根据候选人的不同，民主党人或共和党人当选的可能性大致相同？我的意思是，你如何定义竞争力？是的。我的意思是，在538那种书呆子的世界里，我们将竞争力定义为总统选举中全国平均水平的五个百分点以内。基本上就是一个你预计会有一场势均力敌的比赛的选区。没错。所以这很快就变得非常有争议。你能告诉我们发生了什么吗？当时在2011年，共和党人控制了州议会的两个议院，他们
not all that interested in enhancing competition because enhancing competition would mean probably a better chance that Democrats would take some of those seats away from them. Then on the other hand, of course, Democrats wanted competition. At the heart of this was one woman who was the independent chair of the commission. So the commission is five people, two Republicans, two Democrats, and one independent chair who ends up being the tiebreaker. And if you listen to the episode, you can decide for yourself whether or not that's a good system for creating an independent commission. Ultimately, this independent chair, calling Mathis became the focal point of all of this disagreement between the two parties over how the district should
对提高竞争力并不那么感兴趣，因为提高竞争力意味着民主党人更有可能从他们手中夺走一些席位。另一方面，当然，民主党人想要竞争。这一切的核心是一位女性，她是委员会的独立主席。所以委员会由五个人组成：两名共和党人、两名民主党人，以及一名最终成为决胜票的独立主席。如果你听了那一集，你可以自己决定这是否是一个创建独立委员会的好系统。最终，这位独立主席科琳·马西斯成为了两党之间关于选区应该如何
be drawn, and things actually kind of scary for her to be honest. Okay, so we're going to play a little bit of the Arizona episode of the Jerry Manry Project, which deals with these maps that were drawn to increase competitiveness. And this scene starts in a public hearing about the Mab drawing company that the Independent Commission shows. Let's all rise for the Pledge of Allegiance. I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America. I want to see right now, forgive me, I'm not going to use niceties because I am so upset
绘制的所有分歧的焦点，老实说，事情对她来说变得有点可怕。好吧，我们要播放一点“杰利蝾螈项目”中关于亚利桑那州的那一集，它涉及这些为了提高竞争力而绘制的地图。这一场景开始于一场关于独立委员会选择的地图绘制公司的公开听证会。让我们全体起立，宣誓效忠。我宣誓效忠美利坚合众国国旗。我现在想看看，请原谅，我不会使用客套话，因为我非常愤怒
over this situation. The best way to describe it I think is it was like a beehive. All kinds of people were there and The way they were looking at me I could just tell they weren't happy with me. That's Colleen Mathes. It was June 30th 2011 and she was chairing a public hearing of Arizona's Independent Redistricting Commission. The group of citizens tasked with redrawing Arizona's political boundaries. It was a packed room. It was standing room only. My husband actually was there The group of citizens tasked with redrawing Arizona's political boundaries. It was a packed room. It was standing room only. My husband actually was there and he
关于这种情况。我认为描述它的最好方式是它就像一个蜂巢。各种各样的人都在那里，从他们看我的方式，我能感觉到他们对我并不满意。那是科琳·马西斯。那是2011年6月30日，她正在主持亚利桑那州独立重划选区委员会的公开听证会。该小组由负责重划亚利桑那州政治边界的公民组成。那是一个挤满人的房间。座无虚席。我的丈夫实际上在那里，
went and stood in a doorway. He was concerned, frankly, for the safety of all of us, because it just seemed like a heightened level of intensity. The commission had just decided which mapping company should draw Arizona's new district lines, which are the boundaries that help determine who you vote for. And Republicans weren't happy. So slanted have your votes been against Republicans that there is no question what the goal of this commission is. But what can we expect when the independent is not really an independent?
他站在门口。坦率地说，他担心我们所有人的安全，因为这似乎是一种高度紧张的状态。委员会刚刚决定了哪家地图绘制公司应该绘制亚利桑那州的新选区界限，这些界限有助于决定你投票给谁。而共和党人并不高兴。你们的投票对共和党人如此偏颇，毫无疑问，这个委员会的目标是什么。但当独立人士并非真正独立时，我们能期待什么呢？
She's married to an activist Democrat. One after another each of the people who filled out the request to speak forms came up and pretty much berated me mostly. There are many mapping companies out there. I'm sorry, I am so upset that you could have picked that are non-political. Why didn't you? The mapping company had done work for democratic campaigns and Republicans blamed Mathis for choosing a biased company.
她嫁给了一位激进的民主党人。填写发言请求表的每一个人一个接一个地走上来，基本上主要是斥责我。外面有很多地图绘制公司。我很抱歉，我非常愤怒，你们本可以选择非政治性的公司。为什么不呢？那家地图绘制公司曾为民主党竞选活动工作过，共和党人指责马西斯选择了一家有偏见的公司。
After attending the last two meetings, my feelings are that this is a pre-determined process with one agenda. Remap Arizona to improve democratic representation. What we saw after the mapping in Salt and was appointed was a lot of pitch works and torches here in Arizona because I think the public really knew at that point that the mapping wasn't going to be fair. You know, I thought this commission was supposed to be non-partisan. Damn it! You can't get it anymore partisan than this.
在参加了最后两次会议后，我的感觉是这是一个预先确定的过程，只有一个议程。重划亚利桑那州以改善民主党的代表权。我们在地图绘制顾问被任命后看到的是，在亚利桑那州有很多“干草叉和火把”，因为我认为公众在那时真的知道地图绘制不会是公平的。你知道，我以为这个委员会应该是无党派的。该死！你不可能让它比这更具党派色彩了。
It was scary, frankly. A few weeks after the Apping Consultant decision, a sitting state senator had suggested that it got reported in the press that there was a target on me, and that was scary. He said, quote, the gun is loaded and it's just figuring out what to point it at and when to pull the trigger. According to the Yellow Sheet report, a political newsletter in Arizona, Antonari told the press at the time that he uses military analogies because he was in the military and that he wasn't targeting anyone. When people talk about targets and guns, it's not something to mess with. Only six months earlier,
坦率地说，这很可怕。在地图绘制顾问决定做出几周后，一位在任州参议员暗示，媒体报道说我成了目标，这很可怕。他说，引用：“枪已经上膛了，只是在想瞄准哪里以及何时扣动扳机。”据亚利桑那州的政治通讯《黄页报告》称，安托纳里当时告诉媒体，他使用军事类比是因为他曾在军队服役，他并没有针对任何人。当人们谈论目标和枪支时，这不是可以乱开玩笑的事情。仅仅六个月前，
Mathis' congressional representative had been shot through the head at Point Blink range. I was in Tucson when it happened, and anybody who was in Tucson remembers that day very well because it was a dark day. During a constituent meeting at a grocery store in Tucson, Congresswoman Gabby Giffords and 18 other people were shot. Six died. That unfortunate awfulness occurred in January of 2011 and I was sworn in
马西斯的国会代表在近距离被击中头部。事情发生时我在图森，任何在图森的人都记得那一天，因为那是一个黑暗的日子。在图森一家杂货店举行的选民会议上，国会议员加比·吉福兹和其他18人被枪击。六人死亡。那不幸的恐怖事件发生在2011年1月，而我是在
March of 2011 and so this was that summer after that and it's just it's hard to talk about it. Mathis says she and her husband bought plywood at Home Depot and boarded up their bedroom windows and just ended up kind of making our bedroom at least a safe zone because we just felt kind of like it'd be nice to be able to sleep at night and not worry that somebody was looking in the windows or going to do anything. They also went to the Department of Justice in Washington. We talked to some folks at DOJ and they had an FBI person sit in. Their safety concerns would continue for years to come.
2011年3月宣誓就职的，所以那是那之后的夏天，谈论它真的很困难。马西斯说，她和丈夫在居家百货（Home Depot）买了胶合板，封住了卧室的窗户，最终把我们的卧室至少变成了一个安全区，因为我们觉得如果能睡个安稳觉，不用担心有人在窗外窥视或要做什么，那会很好。他们还去了华盛顿的司法部。我们和司法部的一些人谈过，他们安排了一名联邦调查局人员在场。他们的安全担忧在未来几年里持续存在。
In 2012, with litigation still ongoing, their house was broken into. A year after that, the commission's office was broken into and the computers of all the commissioners were stolen. We don't know if it was related to redistricting, but that did occur. Mathis says her mother told her to quit. But I never was going to quit. But I never was gonna quit.
2012年，在诉讼仍在进行时，他们的房子被闯入。一年后，委员会的办公室被闯入，所有委员的电脑都被偷了。我们不知道这是否与重划选区有关，但这确实发生了。马西斯说她母亲让她辞职。但我从来没想过要辞职。但我从来没想过要辞职。
I just knew that if you quit, you're giving in to, that's exactly what they want you to do. Well, that is really intense. So what happened with these new competitive maps that were drawn in Arizona? You know, the story, it ends up being the most intense, I think, redistricting process, probably the country has ever seen. The governor and legislature impeach mathist and she gets reinstated.
我只是知道，如果你辞职，你就是屈服了，那正是他们想要你做的。好吧，这真的很紧张。那么，在亚利桑那州绘制的这些新的竞争性地图发生了什么？你知道，这个故事最终成为我认为该国可能见过的最紧张的重划选区过程。州长和立法机构弹劾了马西斯，她又被恢复了职务。
Ultimately, they pass the maps and they did end up enhancing competition in Arizona. During the 2016 election, there was one district in Arizona that voted for Hillary Clinton for president and voted for a Republican in the house. And there was another district that voted for Trump as president and voted for a Democrat in the house. That's pretty rare in the United States these days, where we have a very polarized political environment. And generally Democrats and Republicans don't live together. So it's very rare that pretty rare in the United States these days where we have a very polarized political environment and generally Democrats and Republicans don't live together. So it's very rare that we see those kinds of voting patterns. So yes, the districts that they set out to create as competitive districts do function
最终，他们通过了地图，确实在亚利桑那州提高了竞争力。在2016年选举期间，亚利桑那州有一个选区投票支持希拉里·克林顿担任总统，但在众议院投票支持共和党人。还有另一个选区投票支持特朗普担任总统，但在众议院投票支持民主党人。这在当今的美国非常罕见，我们有一个非常两极分化的政治环境。通常民主党人和共和党人不会住在一起。所以我们看到那种投票模式非常罕见。所以是的，他们着手创建的作为竞争性选区的选区确实发挥了
as competitive districts. But of course, the path to getting there was a very acrimony S1. And so I mean, when you went there and did this story, I mean, what did you think of competitiveness as a value when it comes to drawing maps? So it's a complicated one when we look at American politics because you know, we say we want competitive elections and in theory, competitive elections make lawmakers more accountable, right? If you're basically guaranteed to win your primary, win your general election, then you're not that accountable. And if voters don't have options, then do you really live in a representative democracy?
作为竞争性选区的作用。但当然，实现这一目标的道路是非常激烈的。所以，我的意思是，当你去那里做这个报道时，你对作为绘制地图价值的“竞争力”有什么看法？所以，当我们审视美国政治时，这是一个复杂的问题，因为你知道，我们说我们想要竞争性选举，理论上，竞争性选举使立法者更负责任，对吧？如果你基本上保证能赢得初选和大选，那么你就没那么负责任了。如果选民没有选择，那么你真的生活在代议制民主国家吗？
At the same time, patterns in the ways that American voters have clustered make competitive districts really hard to achieve. Republicans and Democrats don't live in similar areas. And less and less American voters switch back and forth between parties from one election to the next. And so you really have to kind of work at creating competitive districts. Okay. So the last day you covered in the Jerry Mandarin Project is California. Like Arizona, they also started an independent commission to redraw districts, but they
与此同时，美国选民聚集方式的模式使得竞争性选区很难实现。共和党人和民主党人不住在相似的地区。而且越来越多的美国选民在选举之间不会在政党之间摇摆。所以你真的必须在创建竞争性选区方面下功夫。好的。那么你在“杰利蝾螈项目”中报道的最后一个州是加利福尼亚州。像亚利桑那州一样，他们也启动了一个独立委员会来重划选区，但他们
did it for a slightly different reason. Here's a clip from that episode. What caused California to create its commission? Did not have to do with the same old partisan type of Jerry Mandarin. It is much more to do with protecting the incumbents. The way they throw the district alliances to protect the incumbents. That's well I'll let him introduce himself. I'm Arnold Schwarzenegger and I was governor of the state of California from 2003 to 2011. He backed redistricting reform as governor and his sins continued to advocate for it.
这样做是出于一个稍微不同的原因。这是那一集的一个片段。是什么导致加利福尼亚州创建了它的委员会？这与那种老式的党派杰利蝾螈无关。它更多地与保护现任议员有关。他们抛出选区联盟以保护现任议员的方式。那是……好吧，我让他自己介绍一下。我是阿诺德·施瓦辛格，我曾于2003年至2011年担任加利福尼亚州州长。他作为州长支持重划选区改革，他的努力仍在继续倡导。
I'm a big believer that we must terminate cherry-mandering in America. When you look at the district lines, the way they're drawn, they make absolutely no sense to anyone, but it is all designed to keep Democrats separate from Republicans. This strategy for drawing maps created an environment in which lawmakers felt entitled to groups of voters they saw as beneficial to them. Without much regard for existing communities or geography. In Los Angeles, for instance, Criatown was split into three or four districts. The Filipino American community was split into two.
我坚信我们必须在美国终止杰利蝾螈。当你观察选区界限时，它们绘制的方式对任何人来说都毫无意义，但这一切都是为了让民主党人与共和党人分开。这种绘制地图的策略创造了一种环境，在这种环境中，立法者认为他们有权获得他们视为对自己有利的选民群体。而不考虑现有的社区或地理位置。例如，在洛杉矶，韩国城被分成了三个或四个选区。菲律宾裔美国人社区被分成了两个。
Kathy Feng is the National Redistricting Director of the nonpartisan group Common Cause. She's also its executive director in California. During the 2001 round of redistricting, she testified to the legislature about how the line should be drawn to keep Asian communities whole. As we traveled up and down the state, we were hearing these stories about people feeling for the first time the importance of talking about their communities. Feng says during the process she got a call from a Democratic Assemblyperson. I had received a phone call from a legislator from San Francisco. And it was my first time talking to, you know, Assemblyperson or a Senator. And as a young attorney, it was quite exciting to receive this phone call.
凯西·冯（Kathy Feng）是无党派组织“共同事业”（Common Cause）的全国选区重划主任，同时也是该组织在加利福尼亚州的执行主任。在2001年的选区重划中，她曾向立法机构作证，说明应如何划分选区以保持亚裔社区的完整性。当我们走访全州时，我们听到了许多关于人们第一次感受到谈论自己社区重要性的故事。冯说，在这一过程中，她接到了民主党议员的电话。“我接到了来自旧金山的一位立法者的电话。那是我第一次与议员或参议员交谈。作为一名年轻的律师，接到这个电话让我感到非常兴奋。”
And this person called me to essentially tell me, Kathy, you're not gonna put another f***ing Asian in my district. I asked her to identify the lawmaker. Carol Mighdon, she's out of office now, so I guess I can say her name. It brought me to tears because it was a realization that we still have
“那个人打电话给我，本质上是为了告诉我：‘凯西，你别想在我的选区里再塞进一个该死的亚裔。’”我请她指认那位立法者。是卡罗尔·米格登（Carol Migden），她现在已经离职了，所以我想我可以直呼其名。这让我流下了眼泪，因为我意识到我们仍然面临着……
a lot of racism in this country and even in a very blue state like California, people come to power with a sense of entitlement that allows them to make decisions about excluding people based on race in order to protect their own seats. When reached for comment, Carol Migndon said she did not recall the conversation. In the end, it was clear that the legislature was not interested in considering public testimony like fangs. What we found out was that after four months of public hearings, the legislature went behind
这个国家仍然存在大量的种族主义，即使是在像加利福尼亚州这样非常支持民主党的州，人们在掌权时也带着一种特权感，这种特权感使他们为了保护自己的席位，可以做出基于种族排斥他人的决定。”当被联系置评时，卡罗尔·米格登表示她不记得有过这次谈话。最终，很明显立法机构对考虑像冯这样的公众证词并不感兴趣。我们发现，在经过四个月的公开听证会后，立法机构转入……
closed doors and drew the lines that they had always intended to. The California Senate passed the maps on September 12, 2001, and the assembly passed them a day later. While the rest of the nation was rocking from this terrorist attack that had happened, and there was essentially a media blackout, quite honestly, there was a real moment of reflection about whether or not our democracy is functioning. Their incumbent protection plan was overwhelmingly successful. The deal that was passed in 2001 made California's map almost impervious to change only one incumbent lost re-election in a general election between 2002 and 2010.
闭门会议，并按照他们最初的意图划定了选区界线。加州参议院于2001年9月12日通过了这些地图，众议院在一天后也通过了。当时全国正因恐怖袭击而动荡不安，基本上处于媒体封锁状态。老实说，当时人们确实在反思我们的民主制度是否还在正常运作。他们的现任议员保护计划取得了压倒性的成功。2001年通过的协议使得加州的地图几乎无法改变，在2002年至2010年间的大选中，只有一名现任议员在连任竞选中落败。
California had insulated itself from the political volatility facing the rest of the country. Few of the races were even close. You had 265 US House races in California. Only 14 of them were decided by less than 10 points. Just 5% of California's congressional elections were competitive. I always said to note that the Soviet Politburo had more change over than our system here in California. So what happened in California? How did they combat this problem of
加州将自己与全国其他地区面临的政治动荡隔绝开来。几乎没有几场竞选是势均力敌的。加州有265个美国众议院选区竞选，其中只有14个选区的胜负差距在10个百分点以内。加州只有5%的国会选举具有竞争性。我常说，苏联政治局的人员变动都比我们加州的系统要多。那么加州发生了什么？他们是如何解决……
and competency bias? California's in the period from the early 2000s to 2010, as you may remember in California, were very, very upset with the state legislature. I mean, at a certain point, I think their approval rating was at 10%, and so you had Governor Schwarzenegger and activists really agitating against the legislature. And so between common cause, the organization that Kathy Fang works with, and other nonpartisan and partisan groups, as well as the governor, they kind of got together and backed a ballot initiative like in Arizona to take the power of drawing these district maps away from the state legislature and to give it to an independent commission. And so what is the basis that they independent commission drew their maps?
以及能力偏见问题的？你可能还记得，在21世纪初到2010年期间，加州人对州立法机构感到非常非常不满。我的意思是，在某个阶段，我认为他们的支持率只有10%。因此，施瓦辛格州长和活动人士真的在反对立法机构。于是，凯西·冯所在的“共同事业”组织与其他无党派和党派团体，以及州长一起，像在亚利桑那州那样推动了一项投票倡议，将划分选区地图的权力从州立法机构手中夺走，交给一个独立委员会。那么，独立委员会绘制地图的依据是什么？
So whereas in Arizona, we had one of the criteria was competitiveness. That was not the case in California. One of the main criteria in California was to respect and empower communities of interest. And that relates to Kathy Fang's experience with the Asian-American community in California and the way that she saw them basically being disregarded in favor of incumbent's own electoral priorities. And so what the Independent Commission did in California was it traveled around the state and listened to members of communities basically say basically define their own communities of interest. And that could range anywhere from Koreatown to one example is a group of people who has horses in LA or one example was even the sound-proofing
在亚利桑那州，标准之一是竞争性，但这在加州并非如此。加州的主要标准之一是尊重并赋权利益相关社区。这与凯西·冯在加州亚裔社区的经历有关，她看到这些社区基本上被忽视，以换取现任议员自身的选举利益。因此，加州的独立委员会在全州范围内走访，倾听社区成员的声音，让他们自己定义自己的利益相关社区。这范围很广，从韩国城，到一个例子是洛杉矶养马的群体，甚至还有一个例子是……
community around the LAX airport in Los Angeles. That's interesting. How successful were they? What did they, what did these maps end up resulting in? Yeah, so one of the complications with this maps end up resulting in? Yeah, so one of the complications with this way of mapping is that it's hard to tell whether or not people are being sincere about what they consider as their communities of interest. Like, political consultants came in and basically organized people around communities that may have been disingenuous in an attempt to influence the map
洛杉矶国际机场（LAX）周围的隔音社区。这很有趣。他们有多成功？这些地图最终产生了什么结果？是的，这种绘图方式的一个复杂之处在于，很难判断人们在定义自己的利益相关社区时是否真诚。例如，政治顾问介入并组织人们围绕某些社区进行诉求，这些诉求可能是虚假的，目的是为了影响地图……
drawing process for partisan reasons. And so there is good reason to believe that they were successful in some cases. Ultimately though, I think California was pretty successful at appeasing both sides of the aisle and getting a relatively fair map. I mean, if you look at different statistical analyses of the vote percentage compared with the seat share, California's maps are pretty fair to Democrats and Republicans. And so what are your takeaways from all this reporting? You were steeped in this for months and months and months and what did you come away with? Indeed I was.
绘制过程，以达到党派目的。因此，有充分的理由相信他们在某些情况下是成功的。但最终，我认为加州在安抚两党并获得相对公平的地图方面做得相当成功。我的意思是，如果你看看投票百分比与席位份额的各种统计分析，加州的地图对民主党和共和党来说都相当公平。那么，你从所有这些报道中得到了什么结论？你沉浸在其中好几个月，你最终得出了什么？确实如此。
So if we, if we look at the four different examples that we've just discussed, first what you'll realize is that all of these different priorities, so one being fairness between the two parties, two being fairness in representing minorities, three being competitiveness in elections, and four being respectful of communities as they exist on a map, you'll start to understand that these things do contradict each other. There are situations in which enhancing the opportunity
如果我们看看我们刚刚讨论的四个不同例子，首先你会意识到，所有这些不同的优先事项——一是两党之间的公平，二是代表少数群体的公平，三是选举的竞争性，四是尊重地图上现有的社区——你会开始明白，这些事情是相互矛盾的。在某些情况下，增加……
for a minority candidate to get elected could put Republicans at an advantage electorally. So ultimately, the people who draw maps have to make difficult value choices. Oftentimes, the people who draw maps only care about partisan advantage, right? And so, you know, that's basically the way that maps have been drawn for a long time.
少数族裔候选人当选的机会，可能会在选举上让共和党人占据优势。因此，最终绘制地图的人必须做出艰难的价值选择。通常情况下，绘制地图的人只关心党派利益，对吧？所以，你知道，这基本上就是长期以来绘制地图的方式。
But if we're going to reform the process, you still have to be awfully thoughtful about the values that you want to prioritize amongst those four things. And which of these four states do you think is doing the best job of this? If you look at California, that is the place where you will talk to both Republicans and Democrats who say that the mapping process overall was fair. And you know, there are obviously Democrats
但如果我们想要改革这个过程，你仍然必须非常慎重地考虑你想要在上述四件事中优先考虑哪些价值。你认为这四个州中哪一个做得最好？如果你看看加州，在那里你会听到共和党人和民主党人都说整体的绘图过程是公平的。当然，显然有民主党人……
Republicans who will disagree with that, but it was a rare example in the months that I spent reporting on this, that you did come to some bipartisan agreement about the success of the results. And is this a function of it being drawn by an independent commission? Is this what the success really points to? You know, I think that's part, oftentimes Americans distrust partisan legislators to put aside their partisanship in order to do what is, quote unquote, fair.
和共和党人会不同意这一点，但在我报道此事的几个月里，这确实是一个罕见的例子，即你能够就结果的成功达成某种两党共识。这是由独立委员会绘制的结果吗？这就是成功的真正指向吗？你知道，我认为这是一部分原因。通常情况下，美国人不信任党派立法者能放下党派偏见去做所谓的“公平”之事。
Obviously, the people who wrote the ballot initiative in California looked at some of these examples in other states. They, you know, there had already been a round of redistricting in Arizona. They had other states to look at as well. And think about where other states may have gone wrong and try to correct for that. You know, you said that the American states are laboratories for democracy. And a result of different states getting to try out, litigate vote for draw maps how they want to, is that we get to see the results
显然，加州投票倡议的起草者研究了其他州的一些例子。你知道，亚利桑那州已经进行了一轮选区重划。他们还有其他州可以参考，并思考其他州可能在哪里出了错，并试图纠正。你知道，你说过美国各州是民主的实验室。而各州能够尝试、诉讼、投票决定如何绘制地图的结果是，我们能够看到……
of a whole bunch of different efforts. And I do think that the people in California were very thoughtful about the way that they wrote the law that guided this process. So what do you expect will come out of the Wisconsin case? Uh, the million dollar question. Honestly, I have no idea. But what I can tell you is this, if Wisconsin Democrats win this case, you will read in
各种不同努力的结果。我确实认为加州的人们在起草指导这一过程的法律时非常深思熟虑。那么你预计威斯康星州的案件会有什么结果？呃，这是个价值百万美元的问题。老实说，我不知道。但我可以告诉你的是：如果威斯康星州的民主党人赢得了这个案子，你会在……
plenty of newspapers, Supreme Court ends gerrymandering. And I can tell you right now that that will basically be a lie because if the Wisconsin Democrats win, what will what it will actually do is start a very long process of determining what ultimately is fair when it comes to partisan advantage in drawing maps, right? I mean, unless the Supreme Court says, you have to use this statistical model and it has to be within this percentage or blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, which I have no reason to believe that they would do,
许多报纸上读到“最高法院终结了杰利蝾螈（不公正划分选区）”。我可以现在就告诉你，这基本上是个谎言。因为如果威斯康星州的民主党人赢了，它实际上会开启一个非常漫长的过程，来确定在绘制地图时，党派优势到底什么是公平的，对吧？除非最高法院说，你必须使用这种统计模型，并且必须在某个百分比之内，等等等等，而我没有理由相信他们会这样做，
then it's going to start a process of a lot of different lawsuits that litigate this in different ways that ultimately try to land on what is fair. And you know what, it could be that we never really land on anything. I mean, that's what's happening with the Voting Rights Act right now, is that we don't have a strong conception
那么它将开启一系列不同的诉讼，以不同的方式进行辩论，最终试图确定什么是公平的。你知道吗，我们可能永远无法真正确定任何事情。我的意思是，这就是《投票权法案》目前正在发生的情况，我们对……
of what is fair in how much to cluster minority voters together, right? That could end up happening with partisan gerrymandering. And you could say that's all worth it, and we need to have that debate. And, you know, we're happy for all the lawyers that are gonna be employed for the coming decades off of all of these lawsuits,
在如何将少数族裔选民聚集在一起方面，什么是公平的，并没有一个强有力的概念，对吧？党派杰利蝾螈也可能发生同样的情况。你可以说这一切都是值得的，我们需要进行那场辩论。而且，你知道，我们为未来几十年因所有这些诉讼而获得就业机会的所有律师感到高兴，
but it's a conversation we need to have. But, you know, even if the Wisconsin Democrats don't win, I don't think that the conversation about Jerry Mandering goes away because as we're seeing even now in Pennsylvania, there are a lot of different avenues to litigate this. And so, no matter what the decision is, in the Wisconsin Supreme Court case, I could promise you that this is going to be
但这确实是我们必须进行的对话。但是，你知道，即使威斯康星州的民主党人没有赢，我也不认为关于杰利蝾螈的对话会消失，因为正如我们现在在宾夕法尼亚州看到的那样，有很多不同的途径可以进行诉讼。所以，无论威斯康星州最高法院的裁决是什么，我可以向你保证，这将是……
a conversation for years to come. So why don't we just have computers draw district lines? Well Galen has an answer for that. After this. So Galen told me that when the Jerry Manoring Project came out, one of the biggest questions they got from listeners was about algorithms. Why not take this whole process out of the hands of humans and just use an algorithm to draw totally random boxes on a map? In some ways, you could.
未来几年的一个话题。那么，为什么我们不直接让计算机来绘制选区界线呢？盖伦（Galen）对此有答案。稍后回来。盖伦告诉我，当“杰利蝾螈项目”发布时，他们从听众那里收到的最大问题之一是关于算法的。为什么不把整个过程从人类手中拿走，只用算法在地图上画出完全随机的方框呢？在某些方面，你可以这样做。
You just write new laws saying that we want an algorithm to draw nice neat shapes on a map. Probably the area where you run into the most trouble is the Voting Rights Act, which specifically requires that minorities not have their votes diluted, and so sometimes, just drawing maps randomly according to shape could potentially violate the Voting Rights Act. On top of that, whether or not we're talking about a minority community, oftentimes people want their community in one district, right? If you're going to have minority community, oftentimes people want their community in one district, right? If you're going to have a representative, you want them to represent something.
你只需写出新的法律，说我们希望算法在地图上画出整齐的形状。你遇到最大麻烦的地方可能是《投票权法案》，它明确要求少数群体的投票权不得被稀释。因此，有时仅仅根据形状随机绘制地图可能会违反《投票权法案》。最重要的是，无论我们是否在谈论少数族裔社区，人们通常希望他们的社区在一个选区内，对吧？如果你要有一个……
And so if you have an algorithm that draws the map randomly, people might not feel like they've been grouped together with their community. An algorithm cannot hold 100 different community meetings and listen to people talk about where their community is. So if you look at California's independent commission website, one of the like commonly asked questions, you know, why doesn't an algorithm do this? And that's what they'll say, you know, an algorithm can't listen to community priorities. Gailin is not against using algorithms in redistricting, but he says they don't change the fact that drawing lines on a map forces you to make difficult choices. You still have to program the algorithm
代表，你希望他们代表某些东西。所以，如果你有一个随机绘制地图的算法，人们可能不会觉得他们被归入了自己的社区。算法无法举行100场不同的社区会议，也无法倾听人们谈论他们的社区在哪里。所以，如果你看看加州独立委员会的网站，其中一个常见问题是：“为什么算法不做这件事？”这就是他们会说的，你知道，算法无法倾听社区的优先事项。盖伦并不反对在选区重划中使用算法，但他表示，它们并不能改变在地图上划线迫使你做出艰难选择的事实。你仍然必须对算法进行编程，
to prioritize certain values the same way that you would have to instruct a legislative body or an independent commission to do that. So, you know, in the program you have to say we want districts to be compact, or we want districts to respect existing municipal boundaries, or we want you algorithm to make the districts competitive. I mean, it's just like algorithms have values, so I don't understand how it would solve it at all. All it really seems to, potentially, solve is calling mathists doesn't get death threats. Right. I think there are plenty of people who will tell you that algorithms have a place in this process,
以优先考虑某些价值，就像你必须指示立法机构或独立委员会那样。所以，你知道，在程序中你必须说我们希望选区紧凑，或者我们希望选区尊重现有的市政边界，或者我们希望你这个算法让选区具有竞争性。我的意思是，算法本身就有价值，所以我根本不明白它怎么能解决问题。它似乎唯一可能解决的问题是，数学家不会收到死亡威胁。对。我认为有很多人会告诉你，算法在这个过程中有一席之地，
and yes, it can make this process easier and potentially fairer, but it's not a silver bullet. That's Galen Druch, host of the Jerry Mand Mandarin Project, a podcast mini-series from 538. Chadwick Matlin was the editor of the project, Kate Back to Erova and Alice Wilder contributed to the production. If you enjoyed this, we really, really encourage you to go listen to the whole series. They gunna do so much more detail, and it was completely fascinating. The team at 538 also put together all of these incredible maps and graphics that you can play around with to try to understand different, disjuretained priorities and how they impact
是的，它可以使这个过程更容易，也可能更公平，但它不是万灵药。以上是538网站播客迷你剧“杰利蝾螈项目”的主持人盖伦·德鲁奇（Galen Druke）。查德威克·马特林（Chadwick Matlin）是该项目的编辑，凯特·巴克-埃罗娃（Kate Back-Erova）和爱丽丝·怀尔德（Alice Wilder）参与了制作。如果你喜欢这个节目，我们真的非常非常鼓励你去听整个系列。他们深入探讨了更多细节，而且非常引人入胜。538的团队还制作了所有这些令人难以置信的地图和图表，你可以尝试操作它们，以了解不同的、被忽视的优先事项以及它们如何影响……
the shapes of the maps. There will be links on our website, 99pi.org. 99% of visible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, Mix and Tech Production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer Kurt Kohlstedt is the digital director. Delaney Hall is the senior editor. The rest of staff includes Avery Trollfmann, Terran Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful,
地图的形状。我们的网站99pi.org上会有链接。《99%无形》（99% Invisible）本周由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，混音和技术制作由谢丽·福塞夫（Sheree Fusef）完成，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特（Kurt Kohlstedt）是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是高级编辑。其他工作人员包括艾弗里·特罗尔夫曼（Avery Trufelman）、泰兰·马扎（Taran Mazza）和我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，制作于美丽的广播街（Radio Row），位于……
downtown, Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by our listeners, just like you. You can find 99% of visible and joined discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have more visual design stories and even videos at nyanipi.org. Radio Topeo from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下RadioTopia的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的集体。我们由像你一样的听众支持。你可以在Facebook上找到《99%无形》并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但在99pi.org上，我们有更多视觉设计故事，甚至还有视频。RadioTopia from PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。